[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bonsoir des enfants mais nounours ne
sert pas si fort ce livre sans ton coeur
tu vas l'abîmé au patron ce n'est pas un
libre souhaite une fortune vous en avez
de la chance mes petits amis
je parie que nounours va vous montrer sa
fortune
seulement s'ils sont sages et un nicolas
et à patronne elle aussi j'y vais mon
échelle hop hop hop hop hop hop hop hop
hop c'est bien savané mais n'atteint
prenait coucou mais je vois qu'on est
propre ce soir vous touchez pas ne
touchez pas avec les mains mouillées
c'est très précieux venez paris ce sont
des merveilles
regardez ces dames au north
ce sont des timbres rares les plus beaux
de ma collection c'est quoi une
collection une collection
seule une collection une collection de
terre c'est quand on a beaucoup de
talent
exactement pareil de renifler nicolas tu
vas faire envoler méthode layati gamme
ça ce sont des très beaux arbres des
sceaux mesures ont plein avec laure
comme d'origine
de très belles pièces arrête de renifler
du cola à voile à la merveille des
merveilles le joyau de ma collection
regards des dieux un timbre très rare et
précieux alors c'est la crs2 un frau
vermion vif 9
nous on continue il est pas n'est ni
tout vient teindre bah ouais
ainsi elle a pas de dantin serait ce qu
en octobre montrent ombre rarissime
où est il ne souffle pas comme souffle
aussi non je vous en plus nos oliviers
baby foot jeux la cheminée
je suis plus arrêté courtial est à 16
octobre maintenant nous sommes montés la
sûreté des allobroges toi bon si par
xinhua
on les drogue et ankara mais vous ne
souffre et plus c'est promis c'est
chiant et nous prend le toit
ap rhône elle mais fait aussi je te
supplie non tiens là voilà ta merveille
tant fait des histoires pour un petit
bout de papier
oh j'ai cru mourir vous m'avez fait le
point pauvre gros noms faut pas avoir
peur comme ça aussi je trouve que c'est
très beau les timbres au long le petit
où nous d'où on va faire une belle
collection aussi n'est ce pas décollé à
l'accord pimprenelle donc tu nous en
apportera d'étape
oui si vous êtes bien sa balle on
dormait fille là j'éteins la lumière
bonne nuit les petits pains henrie
grands collectionneurs
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est fort intéressant de faire une
collection mais il faut être très
soigneux pro seront vite patrons qu
orange ma collection
mon pauvre nounours il ne fallait pas la
porter avec toi je suis trop confiants
patron allons en route
bonnut des enfants faites vite votre
toilette
n'oubliez pas de vous l'a vu le dos et
allez vite vous coucher à demain de pour
eux